الصعب نقل عمق معاناة الشعب السوري ، لقد
كنت بالفعل منزعجًا للغاية وحزينة
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الذي ضرب منذ أكثر من
ثلاثة أسابيع يضيف معاناة يمكن تخيلها
للأشخاص الذين عانوا بالفعل
أكثر من 12 عامًا من
اقتصاد الحرب  انهيار وباء كوفيد -19
وتفشي الكوليرا المستمر
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك على
اعتقادنا أنه يجب استخدام أي معبر
لمساعدة الشعب السوري
يمكن أن يكون عبورًا للحدود عبر
الحدود وهناك المزيد من الفتحات
التي  في الواقع أفضل ، إذا كان هناك
أي وصول يجب استخدامه
لمساعدة الشعب السوري ولا
أعتقد أن الصناعة الحالية
ستكون كافية
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] لقد
بدأنا بالفعل في رؤية بعض
حالات الكوليرا المشتبه بها والتي  هي في الحقيقة
ليست علامة جيدة ليس فقط لشمال غرب
سوريا ولكن لسوريا بأكملها ولكن أيضًا
للقرية بأكملها
[موسيقى]